على المستوى الشخصي انا ضد داخل
المعتقل بسجن تدمر يعني وصلت الى تقريبا
لا استطيع الحركه
نتيجه التعذيب والكذا العمود الفقري كان
مضروب يعني كنت راح انشال يعني
فكنت عالي على الاخرين
بحمامي باكله بشرب
غسيل بهذا لمده كم
لمده تقريبا
انتقلنا وتم علاجي وكذا سويت عمليه جراحيه
طبعا
لكن هاي مسائل كانت قاسيه على الوجدان
وقاسيه على النفس وقاسيه الى درجه انه
ممكن انسان يوصل احيانا لدرجه الياس في
بعض كتير
مساجين يعني
اما انتحر نتيجه وصوله الى نقط الياس معهد
في يستمر الى الواقع اللي موجود فيه حاليا
او الجن يعني بيسموه فصل
فكان في نسبه معينه يعني داخل السجناء
حالتين اساسيتين
ممن ذكرتهما في ذكرتهما في الروايه حضرتك
فيما يتعلق بنسيم الذي ايضا يعني انتحر
لاحقا يعني بعد خروجه من السجن
والحاله الاخرى ايضا ممن جن لم يستطع
التحمل
الواقع هذا الموجود وهذا كان يحصل بسبب
اساسي هو رؤيه ماسي الاخرين مثل رجل كبير
السن الذين اعدموا ثلاثه من ابنائه الشباب
يعني اللي بجن انا يعني كنت اقول لهم صار
نقاش طويل عريض بين
السجناء يعني بيني وبين رفقات داخل السجن
يعني يعني
وين بيكون شخص كثير مرهف الاحساس وكثير
رقيق وكثير حساس وشاعر ما قادر يتحمل على
هذا الواقع
فكنت اللي بجنوا هن الاكثر ذكائنا ولا
اكثر حساسيه والاكثر رقه
هدول يعني مثل ما بيقولوا عنا تمسح وجلده
شوي يعني
بتحمل يعني بيتحمل ولكن يدخل الى عوالم
اخرى
بعد السجن حتى بعد السجن يبقى يعني بدك
فتره زمنيه طويله حسب الحياه اللي بتعيشها
بعد السجن يعني اذا كنت ضمن وسط متفهم
واعي
واحتضنها
وتدرج ممكن ان يخرجك شيئا فشيئا من هذه
القوقعه ممكن
سجنوا حالهم بالبيت بيت اهله مثلا يعني
مثل كانه بيعتادوا على ما كانوا عليه قدره
على التاقلم مع الناس مع الحياه
يمكن يبدو غريب شوي بس هل تشتاق بين قوسين
الى يعني ولو
عم بعرف اشتاق للسجن نعم اشتاق للسجن في
بعض الحالات اشتاق للناس اللي كانوا معي
بالسجن في بعض الحال
عايش معهم اكثر مما عشت مع اخوي
انك تعيش مع شخص عشر سنوات 12 سنه متواصله
24 ساعه من 24 ساعه ايوه دقيقه بدقيقه
تتقاسموا كل شيء تتقاسم الهموم والاحزان
بيعرف عنك وبيعرف عن عيلتك وبيعرف وبتعرف
عنه وبتعرف عن عيلته وبتعرف تفاصيل كلها
يعني بصير في تقريبا مثل النوع من انواع
التوحد يعني
قبل شويه قلت لك يعني وفي نبل
تسقط قيمه الاشياء الماديه في عينيك